not just financially this brings me to
the question that uh that i had to bring
up um doing the research for yourself
you
you just said tax the rich i i believe
um but i thought you were far right and
believed in deregulation and the
billionaires at least that's what the
media tells everybody right
you've come out multiple times saying
these people are getting away with not
paying anything you're getting ripped
off
so the wall street journal dumped out in
the summer 17 i wanted to raise i
to president trump i said we should
raise tax on the wealthy to 44
and on the corporations as they bring
this cash back from overseas right it
ought to be tax less if it's putting
capital equipment and plant and because
we must rebuild the manufacturing base
of this country for the american people
and if you put it in detroit or st louis
or baltimore inner cities you get a
bigger tax cut every piece of capital in
this country that goes into the
manufacturing of putting the capital
equipment to build fourth industrial
manufacturing jobs is going to increase
the ability of the working-class family
look here's the goal we want the ability
i'm not saying women have to do this but
we want the ability to get back to the
50s where one wage earner can have a
family a wife and children or a husband
and children and they don't have to work
unless they want to work we can get back
to that it's no law of meta there's no
second law of thermodynamics that says
we have to have this free trade that
we centered factories all over the world
that we basically put all the burden on
the american
the little guy the american citizen for
all the wars all the taxes everything's
put on his shoulders his or her
shoulders it doesn't have to be that you
should have a special deal if you're an
american citizen right and that deal
deals with let's have a tax policy that
rewards labor and work not just simply
capital because right now it's out of
balance let's get back to a balance
i'm a capitalist i'm not some left-wing
socialist but i got to tell you i say
this all the time unless we reform
capitalism
it this thing's going away there's no
way it's interesting if the money you
held got higher tax rates but the money
you make does has a lower tax rate until
you hold it for like a set amount of
time and then it's the tax rate starts
to go up the longer you hold it let's
talk about negative interest rates
speculation but but here's the thing is
that the wealthy they have this is the
if you go back and look at the 24 people
that are the wealthiest in the nation
they don't pay the pay the taxes of
bloomberg and buffett is like
0.11 because they have all these tax
accountants looking for every deal in
the world that the system
gives them the supposedly for investment
but system gives them to avoid taxes
i will uh counter with this though
taxing them just puts the money into the
government and it's like the government
is free from corruption well first of
all it doesn't totally put the money
first up we've got to pay if we're going
to have a government to provide these
services and has a one trillion dollar
and that's what we have one trillion
dollar defense budget because you add up
all the net all the intelligence and add
in all the areas where they put it down
to other departments it's a trillion
dollars a year if we're going to
continue to spend like this
somehow it's got to be paid for i'm all
for cutting it but still the wealthy
because of their benefits remember think
about it it's it's like the environment
back in the in the in in the 60s or 70s
before we had environmental laws they
had this thing called the commons right
because the effluent you know the hudson
river you you could it was filthy the
air in la you couldn't see through
because to dump everything didn't have
any charge to it and then the people had
a thing to actually to start to charge
for effortless you had the clean air act
and all these things and it got and
those people say oh the libertarian said
you can't regulate but it the water got
cleaner the air got cleaner president
trump says i love clean water i love
clean air hey it all get better why
because the commons we have the same
thing here when people say well steve we
have the most robust liquid capital
markets in the world in the stock market
that's all because of the little guy
it's because it's civic society upon the
shoulders of the working class and
middle class in this country everything
rests okay the cops the teachers the
nurses the people that build the the
coach little league to build the
churches that civic society of america
is what provides for the safety of
investment that's why the whole world
wants to come here and invest their
dollars it's on the shoulders all my
point is hey let's still give a little
something for the effort right i'm not
some radical socialist but if we don't
shift a little more
to the working men and women in this
country right and that's what the apes
are doing they ain't waiting for
regulation you know what they're doing
they're saying hey you're destroying
good american companies it's a rigged
game how about this
buy and hold right and if that if you're
sold this stock short and it goes up
tough that's tough luck we're going to
crush you and they're going to crush
these hedge funds on the way to the
corruption they're going to get to the
casino and they're going to tear the
casino down this is uh
occupy wall street 2.0 it's got a lot of
people on the left younger people
democratic socialists cheering for it
it's got people on the right trump
supporters populist right-wing
individuals
lots of veterans a lot of veterans
it's amazing to hear you know the things
you're saying about the working class
about taxing the rich because i wonder
why it is that we don't see more of the
populist left agreeing
finding out where they agree and what
they can target to change and changing
it
i think they're i think the populist
i've always said a third of the the
bernie let's go back to 16. and
my you know work on populism with
breitbart beforehand 16 was very simple
the reason trump won is that the
american working men and women in
certain middle class people rejected the
managed decline of our country by an
elite of both parties it's wall street
it's the global corporations it's the
uniparty and here's what the thing is
they're comfortable with that managed
decline because they're making more
money on the way down than we made on
the way up okay so it's the managed
decline of our country by the elites and
that's what kind of the trump was the
middle finger to that that's right and
that's and that i think more populous
the one-third of the bernie people
particularly now after two cycles you
didn't win
right because the fight was not the
fight of the people was there but the
fight of the candidates itself was not
there to take on the neoliberal neocons
of which the the clinton apparatus was
in the central apparatus of the
republican party but one of the problems
i see now you know i mentioned this
earlier on in the show friends of mine
from occupy wall street now supporting
the federal government the fbi the
establishment they've abandoned the
populist left and it's just basically
tribalism if if it's bad for the right
they'll cheer for it they're not
interested in improving things i wonder
if a big aspect of it is they're young
and inexperienced and their whole world
is just my side is the right side and we
better win by any means necessary or if
it's just authoritarians who have
manipulated people seized power and
while there certainly were populists at
occupy wall street many uh many of which
i found out later switched and voted for
trump you got jack murphy's book
democrat to deplorable a lot of these
younger people who are in the early 20s
just support the establishment and will
vote for whatever the establishment
wants i'm thinking about the liberal
economic order they built it after world
war ii to prevent world war three the
british and the americans were like
we're gonna set up military bases all
over the world and they basically did
prevent world war three although you
could say now maybe the system's
vestigial and it's ready to be changed
or ripped down or maybe the whole world
could create a world police or something
but people see the value of this
fascistic militarism that's prevented
world war iii and so there is a kind of
a dissonance like
how do we transition away from this let
me go back there i actually think we had
world war iii and uh we won by
information in economic warfare and we
didn't have to go we had to go kinetic
sometimes within korea or or these in
vietnam and other places but we won
because we took down the central
communist apparatus of the soviet union
right we defeated it and i remember in
1989 within a few months of the berlin
wall coming down he had tiananmen square
in tiananmen square we had a moment in
time when the elites in the united
states having take having reagan's let's
we win they lose having the collapse of
the soviet union we could have taken
down the whole thing the ccp would have
collapsed that's where they were in
panic and 30 days after we propped them
up general skullcroft went over from
bush 43 of bush 41 went over there and
basically made a deal with the ccp that
we're going to support you we're going
to orient them because they saw the
ability of the chinese model right to
they always thought they could change
china democrats but they really bought
into the economic model where china
would be the central apparatus of
manufacturing those jobs that all get
shipped over and you essentially use
they say cheap labor slave labor in
china lao beijing old hundred names
would be slave labor and that would
support this international system that's
not a conspiracy them's facts okay and
you can this whole system is predicated
upon that we had we actually won world
war iii
by information and kinetic warfare and
we gave it away and that's what all the
guys just said the end of history and
all this nonsense forgot the fact that
we then went to this kind of global
globalization right predicated around
the slave labor of china that exported
deflation and inability to raise prices
but particularly in a ability to raise
wages because you've always got excess
capacity by the state-owned industries
of china and that's why working people
throughout the world have suffered in
the united states the central economic
point we haven't had an increase real
wages
have not changed except for 19 when
trump had it since 1972-73
working look around anywhere in this
country it's clearly not as good as it
was back 30 and 40 years ago because
you've had a
huge deterioration of of of working
class people ability to have
high-value added high-paying
manufacturing jobs during uh trump uh
trump's administration in 2019
particularly the economy was great jim
cramer said the best number of numbers
of our lives there was something i found
pretty hilarious
the left is advocated for a bunch of
things like four day work week or you
know less hours per day
or more vacation time
paternal leave you know maternal
otherwise
and they want this through regulation
the government should snap their fingers
right down boom make it happen
under trump without regulation it
started to happen there were several
stories i think it was pot belly
sandwiches announced a four-day work
week vacation time we started seeing
that happen in so many different
companies people were making more money
when we were buying furniture for the
first
uh studio setup for this show i went to
a furniture store and the lady told me
she she had never made as much money in
her life as she did in 2019 this is the
beginning of 2020 and i heard the same
thing with the contractor who was doing
work on the house to help us build this
he's like this best year of my life last
year
so all of these things came about
through economic policy under trump but
i'm wondering some people have argued it
was trump just spending like crazy which
was creating an artificial uh bump in
the system that made everyone feel good
but wasn't actually fixing things
curious what your thoughts were with uh
look there's there's a keynesian aspect
of that you know you had you had
spending and you had tax cuts the same
time so double whammy but you also had
restrictions on immigration right which
is a big thing for working for working
class people particularly non-skilled
labor remember it's the chamber of
commerce and it's the republicans want
all that
the democrats want the votes and the
republicans want the cheap labor okay
but also at the higher end i'm a
restrictionist and i also am the leader
of the of one of the leaders of the
freedom movement the chinese people and
i'm the chairman of the of the
republican hindu coalition right so i
love modi i love the nationalism in
india i've got a lot of close friends
but and i chose it but i'm i'm a
restrictionist and the reason is
we need american citizens to get high
tech high if you turn the entire
education system over to stem in grade
school right you need to be able to have
african-american and latino and hispanic
people get into the engineering schools
and get jobs in silicon valley and get
jobs in the fourth industrial revolution
manufacturing jobs this whole thing
we're gonna be a service economy is a
joke one of the biggest things coming
out of here now you see is what's nine
million jobs and they can't phone from
the service economy one-third of the
jobs last for the biden thing the
disastrous job numbers were bartenders
and
and uh and waiters i used to be a
bartender in college i i said but people
don't see it as a career one of the good
things you see people hesitant to come
back one of the reasons is hey i don't
know if i just want to go back to that
grind that has no future to it can't i
do something else that hopefully is the
entrepreneur people want to start
businesses but it's also we must return
to become a manufacturing superpower
anybody that sells you any corporation
any advertisement any politician that
sells you that we can be a service
economy is lying to you is lying to you
you're always going to work for surf
like wages right you're always going to
work like surf like wages until we
return to a manufacturing superpower i'm
a hardcore protectionist i'm hardcore
tariffs and protectionists and not just
that i wouldn't happy talk around these
corporations about you're going to take
your capital and you're going to move it
overseas no you're not until we
understand that manufacturing jobs are
not being outsourced
that capital and investors capital that
belongs here in the united states of
america it's protected and the civic
society has built it we're not communist
we're not socialists but this ability
for this is my problem with the
libertarians they see the free flow of
capital in the free flow of labor and
open borders and open capital markets i
say not so fast we're a country with an
economy we're not an economy first this
whole thing of this austrian school of
economics and all these guys talking
about you know it's like it's like a lot
of guys in the right now say oh it's
just free markets of blackstone and
blackrock are buying up all the housing
stock no it's not we're not we can't
have a system where you buy up all the
housing stock and have the millennials
just rent it back so you're paying your
interest payment and you uh you get the
zero interest rate you get the juice on
the asset increase you can't have a
country like that you're not going to
have firemen you're not going to have
police officers you're not going to have
military to protect you you can't do
this if people don't get skin in the
game and i mean real ownership so they
can sit there and go this is mine i can
pass it on to my kids you're going to
have a system that's going to collapse
you should have been
on day one
in new york at occupy wall street
see what happened was in the early few
days a lot of what you're saying was
what was being said i met an elderly
couple they must be in their 60s with a
big ol american flag talking about how
we got screwed over by the elites how
the big banks were put us off how we
were footing the bill and there were a
lot of people there
but there was no sustained leadership
what happened was
these kind of people are old they have
work to do so they eventually go home
but the trust fund college kids with
nothing but time on their hands and
driven by woke ideology
they would come down and they would
organize the meetings every single day
and over time this weeded out a lot of
the conversations a lot of things that
you you were saying i feel like and
maybe it's just a wishful thinking that
if you or someone like you were there on
day one
someone who is gonna actually
say the things you're saying and
maintain that as the conversation then
the woke takeover of occupy never would
have happened and that would have very
much changed the trajectory of the past
10 years when i was at occupy
in the first week i met luke ridkowski
do you know luke
he's uh what was it luke and anarchist
yeah technically capitalist you love him
he's uh he's a right anarchist this is
his company we are yeah we are changed
we have him on the show every so often
he's up at pork fest the free state
project
i met him down there and he's he's right
libertarian and i was left libertarian
but it was very much like the elites are
screwing us the system and all that
stuff
i remember i was having a conversation
with some people one day and they
announced they were implementing
progressive stack that meant if you want
to speak at any of these meetings and
you were white you're out you're a man
you're out if you were lgbtq you'd have
to announce that to the entire group and
out yourself if you would like to speak
if you were a man
that shut everything down people started
leaving people who were interested in
pushing back against the corruption
started crying i i knew one guy who was
saying a lot of things you were saying
he left crying and never came back
then you look at where
that movement has gone since then and
you know look i i supported bernie
sanders in 2015 and 16. why what did
bernie sanders say to vox.com in the
interview with ezra klein i am not for
open borders that is a koch brothers
proposal they want free labor and i
don't support that what did bernie
sanders then say when he was in the
debate stage in in 2019 2020 how many of
you are in favor of decriminalizing
border crossings they'll raise their
hand how many of you want free health
care for nonsense they all raise their
hand that's not what the left was about
remember the battle the battle in
seattle 1999 was it i was looking i
remember it i learned about it only
through occupy wall street they were
they were opposing the world trade
organization
something happened wto yeah these people
came in during occupy
and because they were young exuberant
and had nothing better to do easily took
it over
and it's a bummer because there were a
lot of people i see i see a lot of
people from occupy who would become
trump supporters trump voters a lot of
people sort of supported bernie then
went to support trump and a lot of those
people are still in the same place as
not necessarily left not really right
but just for the people populist support
manufacturing support the working class
and we're being torn apart by a culture
war we're being torn apart by ideology
this whole thing about critical race
theory and because of that it's
fascinating i'll see people on the left
who completely agree with every
everything you said about increasing
taxes on the wealthy and helping the
working class
but then they'll come out and defend
critical race theory something that we
for instance
absolutely opposed i i oppose because i
come from a second genera i'm second
generation mixed race in my family and
that ideology on editarianism would rip
apart you know the way our family the
way we live so i absolutely have to to
oppose that i feel like that whole
battle has has made it impossible for
the left and right to come together
maybe on purpose it started around
occupy wall street it split everybody up
and now when you see left and right
populists agreeing on core economic
issues they can't agree on these
critical race theory questions
they're not going to come together you
know what i mean i think enough
can agree on the basic economics that we
can transcend this and actually can take
i think you'll see a realignment the key
is like look at the rio grande valley
look at these look at adult look these
are heart that's the most heart scrabble
part of this country is 85 percent
hispanic working class hispanic
very culturally conservative but more
importantly they understand that open
borders is crushing them these are
people that understand i'm an american
citizen i deserve a deal that protects
me and gives me a shot at a good paying
job eventually if i work hard i mean
look at let's go to mr floyd about and i
say this all the time about george floyd
and and i don't want to talk about the
crime that's committed against him
that's a different topic but i said
let's look at his life right when he
died he had ccp virus he had covered 19
he was on fentanyl on opioids right and
he didn't have a great job because all
the manufacturing jobs shipped overseas
think of what george floyd's life would
have been
if we had had a manufacturing base he
would be a supervisor or foreman at a
factory or a junior management he'd be
closing up his
opening up his summer home to go fishing
up in the lake country in minnesota with
his second home up there a little cabin
he could sure
if he if he didn't it didn't have the
the open the opioids that shipped in by
the chinese communist party through the
cartels in mexico across open borders
with everybody making money on the way
up and the huge profits on that to
poison him to poison him and no
opportunity for a job and to top it all
off the chinese communist party virus
that the elites in the in the scientific
priesthood has basically helped fund and
helped do he had the ccp covet 19 virus
in him he had the virus in him had
fentanyl in him he didn't have access to
a great job because all the great
manufacturing jobs are shipped off look
that's the track that's the greek
tragedy to me of george floyd is that he
was in that position that day and by the
way let's talk about the fake 20. that's
also the ccp and we know that these
foreign entities are putting out this
fake money all the time with the opioids
to do it that was what the the
counterfeit bill was every aspect of his
life driven by geopolitics that led to
that thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you